It's one thing to go through something so horrible that you think you're gonna die. And it's another to go through something so horrible you think you're going to die, and it's exactly what you always expected.
经历如此可怕的事以至于以为自己会死是一回事，但经历如此可怕的事以为自己会死，而且那正是你一直预料会发生的事，又是另一回事。
I've always been scared of flying. I have several different scenarios in my head that I imagine. Some involve collisions with other planes. The plane stalling and plummeting. You know, just precipitous nosedives.
我一直很怕坐飞机。我的脑海里想象过好几种不同的场景。有些涉及与其他飞机相撞、飞机失速坠落，你知道，就是那种急剧的俯冲。
Alexandra Jacobs was on that Jet Blue flight a couple weeks ago. The one where the landing gear turned perpindicular, and they made an emergency landing on live national television. She was six and a half months pregnant, taking one last trip to the East Coast from LA before the baby be born.
亚历山德拉·雅各布斯（Alexandra Jacobs）几周前就在那架捷蓝航空（JetBlue）的航班上。就是起落架垂直卡住，迫使他们在全国直播的电视上进行紧急迫降的那次。她当时怀孕六个半月，在孩子出生前，从洛杉矶去东海岸做最后一次旅行。
I'm usually most scared on take off, and then once there's a little ding ding and it's now safe to use portable electronic devices, I'm pretty much fine for the duration of the trip. This time, that comforting ding ding did not occur, and we just weren't ascending at the normal rate.
我通常在起飞时最害怕，一旦听到那声“叮叮”，提示现在可以安全使用便携式电子设备了，在剩下的航程里我就基本没问题了。但那次，那种让人安心的“叮叮”声没有响起，我们也没能按正常速度爬升。
And the pilot got on. And he said, "Well, folks." And you know, I have this joke that whenever a pilot says "folks," it's never good news.
飞行员通过广播说：“各位，大家伙儿。”你知道，我有个笑话，只要飞行员一说“大家伙儿”，就准没好事。
The pilot tells everybody that he's getting a signal that the landing gear won't retract. And really it might just be that the signal is screwed up. The landing gear may have retracted just fine. Technicians on the ground are using fancy satellite communications gear to check the plane's systems, which Alexandra found reassuring. It all sounded routine. Sounded high-tech.
飞行员告诉大家，他收到的信号显示起落架无法缩回。实际上，可能只是信号出错了，起落架可能已经缩回去了。地面的技术人员正在使用精密卫星通信设备检查飞机系统，这让亚历山德拉感到心安。这一切听起来很常规，听起来很高端。
But then he said that we were going to do a low flyby, and that people on the ground were going to inspect the underbelly of our plane with binoculars to see what was wrong with the landing gear. And I thought, my God. Like that's how they're going to, you know, check out the safety of the plane? With binoculars? Like the ones my husband uses for birdwatching? You know, it just didn't seem-- it seemed very retro, you know, to have someone peering at our plane.
但随后他说我们将进行低空飞越，地面人员将用双筒望远镜检查飞机的腹部，看看起落架出了什么问题。我心想，天哪，他们就是这样检查飞机安全的吗？用双筒望远镜？就像我丈夫观鸟用的那种？你知道，这看起来真的很复古，居然有人盯着我们的飞机看。
I don't think people began to sort of panic and cry and get upset until the words "emergency landing" were bandied about.
我觉得直到“紧急迫降”这个词被提出来，人们才开始有点恐慌、哭泣和不安。
We have run all the relevant checklists and are confident that we know exactly what the issue is, as well as the issues to be dealt with.
我们已经运行了所有相关的检查清单，确信我们清楚问题所在，也知道该如何处理。
This is sound from a video camera that a passenger pulled out once it became clear that something unusual was happening on the flight.
这段声音来自一位乘客拍摄的视频，一旦很明显航班发生了不同寻常的情况，他就拿出了摄像机。
At this point, what I'm doing is burning off additional fuel.
此时，我正在做的是消耗掉多余的燃油。
And almost simultaneously, or very close to that announcement, I looked a couple of rows in front of me, and saw that someone's television had imagery of a plane circling in a blue sky. And I heard someone say, that's our plane. We're on MSNBC.
就在那条公告发布的同时，或者非常接近的时候，我看了看我前面的几排，看到某个人的电视屏幕上显示着一架飞机在蓝天中盘旋。我听到有人说，那是我们的飞机，我们在MSNBC的新闻里。
Good evening, everyone. I'm Colette Cassidy. We are breaking in to Hardball with this live picture of a JetBlue airplane, that is flight 292--
各位晚上好，我是科莱特·卡西迪（Colette Cassidy）。我们现在插播《Hardball》节目，画面中是捷蓝航空的一架飞机，即292号航班——
As you may have heard from the coverage of this story, JetBlue planes have satellite receivers, so each seat on a plane gets live DIRECTV on a little screen.
正如你可能从这则新闻的报道中听到的那样，捷蓝航空的飞机配备了卫星接收器，所以飞机上的每个座位都可以通过小屏幕收看直播的DIRECTV电视节目。
I've been told by both the company as well as our in-flight crew that apparently we've made the news. I'm sorry about that. I apologize for any apprehension that this has caused to you. I want to assure you--
公司和机组人员都告诉我，显然我们上了新闻。对此我深表歉意。我很抱歉这给你们带来了恐慌。我想向你们保证——
I mean, I think that ratcheted up the level of alarm, because it wasn't local news. It was national news. It was in the same text zipper as Hurricane Rita. It was on multiple channels. People were flipping around and they're like, oh my God, it's on FOX, it's on ABC. You know, and we're all familiar with these national events that take over your television, where you flip from channel to channel and it's the same image.
我的意思是，我觉得这加剧了警报级别，因为它不是地方新闻，而是全国新闻。它和飓风丽塔（Hurricane Rita）出现在同一条滚动新闻栏里。它在多个频道播放。人们在频道间切换，他们会想，噢天哪，福克斯在播，ABC也在播。你知道，我们都熟悉这些占领你电视机的全国性事件，你在不同频道间切换，看到的都是同一个画面。
Right. You are in the white Bronco, all of a sudden.
没错。你突然就成了那辆白色野马（Bronco）里的人。
Exactly. It wasn't a good feeling.
没错，这种感觉真不好。
For years, Alexandra has been having these conversations with her husband and his brother and his dad-- the brother and dad were actually Navy pilots-- about whether flying was safe. Alexandra, of course, said that it was not. And the thought went through her head right now that well, if we crash, at least I win that argument.
多年来，亚历山德拉一直与她的丈夫、小叔子和公公——小叔子和公公实际上是海军飞行员——讨论飞行是否安全。亚历山德拉当然说不安全。现在她脑子里闪过一个念头，好吧，如果我们要坠机了，至少我赢了那场争论。
I always knew I was going to perish in a plane crash, and you know, it's just coming true. Here it is.
我一直都知道我会死于空难，现在你知道了，它真的发生了。就是这样。
Well, today on our radio program, stories of people who thought they were goners, and what they say once it's clear that they're back from the dead. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
好吧，今天在我们的广播节目中，我们要讲那些以为自己必死无疑的人的故事，以及当他们死里逃生后会说些什么。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Our program in three acts today. In the first act, we hear from more passengers from JetBlue flight 292 about what it's actually like to be on a plane that you think might be doomed. Act Two, ""P' is for Port-A-Potty" in which you visit a town that might not actually recover after Hurricane Katrina. Act Three. "Friday Night Floodlights." A story of a town that is actually near that town in Act Two, which doesn't have a high school up and running yet, but all kinds of people have turned their lives upside down to restart high school football. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目分三幕。第一幕，我们听听更多292号捷蓝航班乘客的亲身经历，了解在以为自己可能在劫难逃的飞机上究竟是什么感受。第二幕，“P代表移动厕所（Port-A-Potty）”，我们将走访一个在飓风卡特里娜（Hurricane Katrina）袭击后可能无法真正恢复的小镇。第三幕，“周五晚上的泛光灯”。这是一个离第二幕小镇不远的小镇的故事，那里还没有像样的高中，但所有人为了重启高中橄榄球赛，不惜颠覆了自己的生活。请继续收听。
Act One. In the Event of an Emergency.
第一幕，紧急情况下。
So in addition to Alexandra Jacobs, I talked to two other passengers from that JetBlue flight.
所以除了亚历山德拉·雅各布斯，我还采访了那架捷蓝航班上的另外两名乘客。
We basically had three hours total of flying in circles.
我们基本上总共在空中盘旋了三个小时。
Zach Mastoon was sitting in the very back of the plane.
扎克·马斯通（Zach Mastoon）当时坐在飞机的最后面。
It was terrifying. I quickly asked the stewardess for a drink. It never happened. I never got the drink. They didn't do any service. There was just too much going on. And I was seated next to this really nice guy. He's in real estate. His name was AJ. He was really my angel. And he offered me this large bottle of what looked like seltzer, and he said, hey, you can have a swig of this. It's leaded.
太可怕了。我很快问空姐要杯饮料。结果没下文。我没喝到饮料。他们没有任何服务。事情太多了。我坐在一个非常好的人旁边。他是做房地产的。他叫AJ。他简直是我的天使。他递给我一大瓶看起来像苏打水的东西，说，嘿，你可以喝一口。这是加了“料”的。
So I started drinking this really strong vodka tonic. And it was brilliant. It really took the edge off, and allowed me to look at the situation in a much more accepting way? If I hadn't had something to drink-- I know that sounds sort of pathetic, but worrying, and you know, freaking out, watching the news and hearing commentators tell me that I could die in a ball of fire wasn't, you know, what I wanted to do. So I flipped on Comedy Central. Started watching The Daily Show .
于是我开始喝这种非常强劲的伏特加汤力水。真是太棒了。它真的缓解了我的紧张，让我以一种更平和的心态看待这种情况。如果我没喝点什么——我知道这听起来很可怜，但在那种情况下，担心，你知道，抓狂，看着新闻，听评论员说我可能会在火球中丧生，那不是我想做的事。所以我打开了喜剧中心频道（Comedy Central），开始看《每日秀》。
People were up and about more than I would have thought they would be. Just getting their stuff, or going to the bathroom, or you know, whatever.
人们走动得比我想象的要多得多。只是去拿东西，或者去洗手间，或者什么的。
Dave Reinitz is the guy who was shooting videotape on the flight, sitting in seat 18D.
戴夫·雷尼茨（Dave Reinitz）是那个在飞机上拍摄录像的人，坐在18D座位。
Yeah, people were-- there was some talking. But people, I think, were very in their own heads, and very-- trying to get their emotions in check for what was happening.
是的，人们……是有一些交谈。但我认为，人们沉浸在自己的思想中，并且非常……试图控制自己的情绪以应对正在发生的事情。
Nobody was making a spectacle out of themselves, and no one was really, like, just going bananas.
没有人哗众取宠，也没有人真的抓狂。
It was very tense. I mean, everyone was dealing with it in his or her individual style. You had the weepers. You know, it was later reported that grown men were crying, but I didn't observe any. I just saw a couple of women were crying. You had the stoics. And they were just sort of acting like-- just, you know, inside themselves. They weren't really expressing anything. And then you had these sort of chirpy, road warrior types who were laughing and joking, telling their harrowing experiences in previous flights.
气氛非常紧张。我是说，每个人都在以他或她自己的方式应对。有爱哭的人。你知道，后来有报道说成年男性在哭泣，但我没看见。我只看到几个女人在哭。还有那些坚忍的人。他们表现得就好像……沉浸在自己的世界里。他们并没有真正表达什么。然后还有那种兴高采烈的“空中飞人”，他们笑着开玩笑，讲述自己在以前航班上的惊险经历。
There was a real camaraderie among the passengers, and everybody was really understanding, and just sort of humbled. And in fact, before we were landing, they moved a lot of the passengers to the back of the plane, and this woman was seated in between AJ and me--
乘客之间确实有一种友情，大家都很体谅，而且都变得很谦卑。事实上，在降落前，他们把许多乘客转移到了飞机后部，这个女人就坐在AJ和我之间——
To make the front of the plane lighter?
为了让机头变轻？
Yeah, possibly. They did it, anyway, and they moved some of the luggage back. And this woman was seated between AJ and me, and she started showing us pictures of this wedding that she had just attended. And it was this really intimate moment that would have never-- she would have never showed the photos to anybody.
是的，可能吧。总之他们这么做了，还把一些行李移到了后面。这个女人坐在AJ和我之间，她开始给我们看她刚参加的那场婚礼的照片。那真是一个非常亲密的时刻，绝不可能——如果不是在那种情况下，她绝不会给任何人看这些照片。
The strangest thing about the videotape of the flight is how normal everything looks. There is one long close-up shot of two hands. An older couple, across the aisle from Dave. And he filmed their hands, squeezing. The woman rubbing her thumb over the back of her husband's hand for a long time.
关于这段飞行录像，最奇怪的事情就是一切看起来是多么正常。有一个长镜头特写是一双紧握的手。一对老年夫妇，坐在戴夫对面的过道。他拍下了他们紧握的双手，女人的大拇指一直在揉搓着丈夫的手背。
You know, I was carrying some extra tension that day, because I'd had a big argument with my girlfriend. We'd left on very tense terms.
你知道，那天我带着一些额外的压力，因为我和女朋友吵了一架。我们离别时气氛非常紧张。
So you're on the plane thinking about the fact that you just had this huge fight.
所以你在飞机上想到你们刚刚大吵了一架。
I'm thinking about the fact that she could be at home watching this, knowing that we'd had some harsh words before I left, and how difficult that would be for her if anything happened to me. So I took a few minutes, and you know, first I said to the guy next to me, listen, I'm going to say some things. And then I turned the camera on myself, and I said some things to Barbara.
我想到她可能在家里看着电视，知道我走之前我们说了些重话，如果我出了什么事，这对她来说该有多难过。所以我花了点时间，首先我对旁边的人说，听着，我要说点话。然后我把摄像机对着自己，对芭芭拉（Barbara）说了一些话。
Hey Barb, it's me. I'm watching the plane on the TV. We're having landing gear problems. We're going to crash land, or emergency land-- crash is a bad word-- in LAX. Just thought I'd leave you a message, just in case. I love you. Everything is going to be groovy. And we'll have a good laugh when I show you this video, and you see what a goober I am. But if anything happens, you know, take care of everything. Everything's yours. You know?
嘿，芭芭拉，是我。我正在电视上看着我们的飞机。我们遇到了起落架故障。我们要迫降，或者紧急降落——“坠毁”这个词太难听了——在洛杉矶机场（LAX）。只是想以防万一留个言。我爱你。一切都会好起来的。等我给你看这段视频，你会看到我有多笨拙，到时候我们一定会大笑的。但如果发生了什么事，你知道，照顾好一切。一切都是你的。你懂的？
You know, my family was great. They were making big fun of me about that. Oh, you left her everything? Oh, the '91 Toyota and the credit card bills, everything, huh? Yeah.
你知道，我的家人很棒。他们拿这个跟我开大玩笑。噢，你把一切都留给她了？噢，那辆91年的丰田车和信用卡账单，所有的一切，是吗？是啊。
There's been a bunch of press attention to the fact that there were people writing goodbye notes and things like that. Did you see people doing that?
媒体报道了人们在写遗书之类的事情。你看到人们这么做了吗？
I did not. And really, if we all burned up, those notes would have been incinerated, anyway.
我没看到。而且说真的，如果我们真的烧成了灰烬，那些纸条也早就被焚毁了。
Yeah.
是啊。
The guy two seats to the right of me-- he was this calm suit. Once he told me that an expert-- an aviation expert on the ground that had been summoned by one of the studios, had said that it would probably be OK, and that it might be messy, but that it wouldn't be catastrophic, that was probably the most reassuring bit of information I got during the entire ordeal.
坐在我右边两排的那个人——他是个冷静的职业人士。一旦他告诉我，地面上某位被电影公司召集来的航空专家说，大概率没事，可能会比较混乱，但不会是灾难性的，这可能是我在整个过程中听到的最令人安心的消息了。
So the TV actually turned out to be sort of comforting.
所以电视实际上还起到了一些安慰作用。
Yeah. After the initial shock of seeing it. Yeah. I was glad to have it.
是的。在最初的震惊之后。是啊。我很高兴有电视。
Wow. So in sum, actually, if you had a choice, you'd rather have had the TV?
哇。所以总的来说，如果让你选，你宁愿看电视？
Yeah. Well, no, I have to qualify that. I would rather have never seen it on TV, but given the fact that the TV was there, it turned out to be more reassuring.
是的。嗯，不，我得澄清一下。我宁愿从来没在电视上看到这事，但既然电视在那里，它反而成了更令人安心的东西。
One of the commentators said, well, I can't imagine that the people are all watching TV. You know, JetBlue has television. I'm sure they're all getting ready to brace themselves and learning about the emergency procedure. And at that point, the whole cabin kind of erupted in laughter. I guess a lot of people were watching the same channel.
其中一位评论员说，嗯，我无法想象人们都在看电视。你知道，捷蓝航空有电视。我相信他们都在准备采取防冲撞姿势，并了解紧急程序。就在那一刻，整个机舱爆发出了一阵笑声。我想很多人都在看同一个频道。
So during this two hours after you find out you're going to make an emergency landing, Alexandra, as somebody like you, who actually has to stop herself from picturing the different ways your plane can go down, are you actually picturing it, now that you're in a situation where--?
所以在那两个小时里，当你发现你要紧急迫降后，亚历山德拉，作为一个像你这样，实际上不得不阻止自己去想象飞机坠毁方式的人，既然你现在处于这种情况，你真的在脑补吗——？
No, I wasn't-- I mean, I was, in a strange way, growing calmer and calmer and more and more rational. You know, I'd been in this fatalistic mode of yup, I'm going to die in a plane crash, just as I always thought. But then as the emergency landing became more and more real, I thought, the pilot doesn't want to die. Nobody on the ground wants us to die. Everybody is doing their absolute best. You know, I'm really well-positioned. I'm in a seat behind the exit row. And I'm just going to be one of the first people out. I'm going to run straight into my husband's arms. I have a really good chance of surviving.
不，我没……我的意思是，奇怪的是，我变得越来越冷静，越来越理性。你知道，我一直处于这种宿命论模式，觉得“没错，我就要死于空难了，正如我一直想的那样”。但随着紧急迫降变得越来越真实，我想，飞行员不想死。地面上没有人希望我们死。每个人都在竭尽所能。你知道，我的位置非常好。我坐在出口排后面。我一定会是最先出去的那批人之一。我要直接奔向我丈夫的怀抱。我很有机会存活。
And before the actual landing, like, as you're coming in for that final descent, did you think then, oh, I guess I could die now?
那在真正降落之前，就在你进行最后下降时，你有想过，噢，我现在可能会死吗？
No. I no longer believed that it would happen. I no longer believed that we would crash and die.
没有。我不再相信那种事会发生了。我不再相信我们会坠机并死去。
Why?
为什么？
There had been so much of a buffer of time and thinking about it, and everyone saying it's going to be OK, that when it actually happened, I was no longer afraid.
因为有太多的缓冲时间和思考空间，加上每个人都在说会没事的，所以当事情真正发生时，我已经不再害怕了。
It's almost like you got bored with being afraid.
就像是你对恐惧感到厌倦了。
I got tired of being afraid, yeah.
我确实厌倦了恐惧，是的。
The pilot told us that we were beginning our final descent, and I think he even said, "Flight attendants, prepare for arrival."
飞行员告诉我们正在开始最后降落，我想他甚至说了：“乘务员，准备抵达。”
Wait, you laugh as you say that, because--?
等等，你说这话的时候笑了，因为——？
Well, because it's such a mundane announcement. I mean, that's what they say on every normal flight.
嗯，因为这是一个如此平凡的公告。我的意思是，那是他们在每次正常航班上都会说的。
So I can't remember whether it was the pilot or the flight attendants, but we were told that we were going to hear an automated announcement. And as we came in for our landing, a mechanized voice came over the loudspeaker and said "Brace! Brace!" That was very scary, because that's when you were in the reality of, oh my God it's an emergency landing, it's a real emergency landing. A warning signal has taken over. Because whenever-- I don't know about you, but I've read black box recordings. And you read in the black box recordings transcripts about the various signals of the plane that take over.
所以我记不清是飞行员还是乘务员说的了，但我们被告知会听到自动广播。当我们准备降落时，一个机械的声音通过扬声器说：“采取防冲撞姿势！采取防冲撞姿势！”那非常可怕，因为那时你才真正进入现实，噢天哪，这是一次紧急迫降，真正的紧急迫降。警报信号占据了一切。因为无论什么时候——我不知道你怎么样，但我读过黑匣子记录。你在黑匣子记录的抄本中读到过飞机上占据主导的各种警报。
Brace! Brace! Brace!
采取防冲撞姿势！采取防冲撞姿势！采取防冲撞姿势！
And then what was absolutely remarkable to me was that the flight attendants continued to repeat this mantra of "Brace! Brace!"
然后最让我震惊的是，空乘人员不断重复这个口令：“采取防冲撞姿势！采取防冲撞姿势！”
And I kept waiting for it. I kept waiting for the thing to snap. I kept waiting for a big hit. You can actually hear me on the tape saying, "Come on! That's it? That's all you've got?"
我一直等着它发生。我一直等着飞机断裂。我一直等着猛烈撞击。你实际上可以在录像里听到我说：“来吧！就这？你就这点本事？”
Gently the nose just got let down. We smelled some smoke and a little bit of the burning rubber.
机头轻轻地放下了。我们闻到了一些烟味和一点橡胶烧焦的味道。
And a voice inside my head said, it's OK. You're smelling burning rubber because the tire is burning off, and you know, that's what it is.
我脑子里有个声音说，没事的。你闻到橡胶焦味是因为轮胎在燃烧，你知道，就是这样。
It was so incredibly smooth, it was almost anticlimactic.
它太顺滑了，甚至显得有点虎头蛇尾。
Dave Reinitz, Zach Mastoon, and Alexandra Jacobs, passengers in JetBlue flight 292.
戴夫·雷尼茨、扎克·马斯通和亚历山德拉·雅各布斯，捷蓝航空292号航班的乘客。
[MUSIC - "YOU ARE AN AIRPLANE" BY OF MONTREAL]
[音乐 - 蒙特利尔乐团的《你是一架飞机》]
Act Two. "'P' is for Porta-Potty."
第二幕，“P代表移动厕所”。
Since Hurricane Katrina, lots of towns are trying to come back from nothing. New Orleans has gotten so much attention, but there are dozens of tiny New Orleanses all along the Gulf Coast, towns actually harder hit by the storm than New Orleans.
自从卡特里娜飓风以来，许多城镇试图从一无所有中回归。新奥尔良得到了太多的关注，但沿海地区沿线有几十个像新奥尔良一样的小城镇，它们受灾的情况实际上比新奥尔良更严重。
One of them, a town called Pearlington in Mississippi, is just over the Louisiana border. It's about 10 miles inland and 45 miles from New Orleans. About 1,600 people live there. Or did, anyway. The county that it's in, Hancock County, is the Ground Zero of Hurricane Katrina, in terms of devastation.
其中一个叫珀林顿（Pearlington）的密西西比小镇，就在路易斯安那州边境对面。距离内陆约10英里，距新奥尔良45英里。大约住着1600人。或者说，曾经住着那么多。它所属的汉考克县（Hancock County），就破坏程度而言，是卡特里娜飓风的“原爆点”。
Around Pearlington, the estimated death toll is 80 to 90 people. One of our show's producers, Sarah Koenig, visited to see how they're doing.
在珀林顿周围，估计死亡人数为80到90人。我们节目的制片人之一莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）去那里看了看他们的现状。
It's hard to overstate how small and isolated Pearlington was. Most people didn't have computers at home, never mind internet. And the only copy machine in town was at the elementary school, which doubled as the public library. And some of the school kids had never been outside the town. When the first graders made a book about Pearlington called The ABCs of Pearlington. "I" wasn't, say, ice cream or IHOP.
珀林顿是多么渺小和孤立，怎么强调都不为过。大多数人家里没有电脑，更不用说互联网了。镇上唯一的复印机在小学里，它兼作公共图书馆。一些小学生从未离开过镇子。当一年级的孩子制作了一本关于珀林顿的书，叫《珀林顿的ABC》时，“I”指代的并不是冰淇淋或IHOP（餐馆）。
"I" was the interstate, and the picture was the interstate with all the little dotted line of cars on it. "J" was the junkyard. "K," what was "K"?
“I”是州际公路，图片画的就是那条有着一连串小点点汽车的州际公路。“J”是垃圾场。“K”是什么呢？
That's Jeannie Brooks, the school librarian in Pearlington. She was my host, and the first day I followed her into town. Just a two-lane road and trees for miles. You'd never know a town was back there.
那是珍妮·布鲁克斯（Jeannie Brooks），珀林顿学校的图书管理员。她是我的向导，第一天我跟着她进镇。只有一条双车道公路和几英里的树林。你永远不会知道后面藏着一个小镇。
15 miles outside of Pearlington, I got my first shock. I was following Jeannie in her truck, and she stuck her arm out the window and pointed.
在珀林顿外15英里处，我第一次受到了冲击。我开着卡车跟着珍妮，她把胳膊伸出窗外指着。
Oh. Wow. Tombs. Holy crap. There are just tombs on the side of the road. Like coffins. Like coffins are just sitting on the side of the road. White coffins with lids. Luckily they're closed. Oh my God.
噢。天哪。墓地。天呐。路边居然有墓穴。就像棺材一样。就像棺材直接放在路边。白色的棺材盖着盖子。幸好它们关着。噢天哪。
This part of the country isn't very high above sea level, so when the cemeteries flooded, the caskets just came floating up out of the ground. The ones I saw had landed in some bramble on the other side of the highway.
这个地区海拔不高，所以当公墓被淹时，棺材就直接从土里漂了出来。我看到的那些落在了公路另一边的荆棘丛里。
Pearlington was, if possible, even more shocking. The entire town is gone. The streets have been cleared by now, so you can see the plan of what was the town. But on either side of the roads, where the houses used to be, there's carnage. Some houses have collapsed on themselves. Some, the wind has stripped to the frame, so they almost look like new construction. As people showed me their homes, it was hard to know how to react.
如果可能的话，珀林顿的情况更令人震惊。整个城镇都不见了。街道现在已经被清理过了，所以你能看出城镇的规划蓝图。但在道路两旁，曾经的房子所在地，全是残骸。有些房子倒塌了，有些房子被风吹得只剩下框架，看起来几乎像是在施工中的新房。当人们向我展示他们的房子时，我不知道该作何反应。
Which is your house? Behind? Oh my God!
哪栋是你的房子？后面那栋？噢天哪！
It's a mess, ain't it?
是一团糟，对吧？
Well, it's just so-- that tree is so perfectly crushing your house. I'm sorry to laugh, but it's so shocking.
嗯，只是……那棵树正好压垮了你的房子。对不起我不该笑，但这太震惊了。
It's a mess. Along with the water that went through it.
是一团糟。连同冲进房子里的水。
The hurricane had pushed a 25-foot wall of ocean water 10 miles inland from the Gulf. Afterwards people saw fish, like sting rays, and speckled trout, and shrimp just swimming around in ditches. Everything was flooded.
飓风将25英尺高的海水推进到了内陆10英里。事后人们看到了鱼，比如黄貂鱼、斑点鳟鱼，还有虾在沟渠里游来游去。一切都被淹了。
So some houses looked intact, but when you went inside, the floors were blanketed with mud. And not the friendly mud you played in as a kid, but a kind of noxious, slimy paste. You could see the waterline near the ceilings.
所以有些房子看起来完整，但当你进去时，地板上铺满了泥巴。不是小时候玩的那种友好的泥巴，而是一种有害的、黏糊糊的糊状物。你可以看到天花板附近的水位线。
Richard Clark had one of the few two-story houses I saw in town, a beautiful house he built himself. We walked up the staircase, above the waterline.
理查德·克拉克（Richard Clark）在镇上拥有为数不多的二层小楼之一，那是一栋他自己建造的漂亮房子。我们走上楼梯，到了水位线以上的地方。
Now, this is beginning to look like some of what the house was.
现在，这开始看起来像房子本来的样子了。
So it's so crazy, because up here it's like the carpet is clean. It looks like it's just been vacuumed. Here's a bedroom, perfectly fine. Smells nice. Fresh. It's so weird. You would never know. If you were asleep up here, you would never know.
这太疯狂了，因为楼上地毯是干净的。看起来像是刚刚吸过尘一样。这是一个卧室，非常完美。味道也很香。新鲜。太奇怪了。你永远不会知道。如果你在这里睡觉，你永远不会知道下面发生了什么。
We might sleep up here, once we get things straight. Maybe.
我们等把事情理顺了可能会在这里睡。也许吧。
Which would be a fine idea, except for the mold, which has been growing for a solid month in the more than 100 degree heat. When you go inside a house like this, you can instantly feel it shoot down your throat. It burns a little bit.
除了霉菌，这是一个好主意。在那100多度的高温下，霉菌已经生长了一个多月了。当你走进这样的房子时，你会立即感觉到霉菌直冲喉咙。有点刺痛。
The maps that fire and rescue teams were using to help Gulf Coast towns didn't even show Pearlington, and organized relief didn't come for about 10 days. So now, a month after the disaster, hundreds of people-- no one knows exactly how many-- are living in tents on their property next to their decimated houses. Just camping there amid the trash and stinking water and debris.
消防和救援队用来帮助沿海城镇的地图上甚至没有标注珀林顿，组织性的救援在10天后才到。所以现在，灾难发生一个月后，数百人——没人确切知道有多少——住在他们被毁坏的房子旁边的帐篷里。就在垃圾、发臭的水和残骸中露营。
So both of you are in here?
所以你们俩都住在这里？
That's my bunk and here's mother's.
那是我的铺位，这是妈妈的。
I hung out for a while with Mary Lou Brooks and her mother, Pauline Davidson. They're both widows, and they live on the same three-acre property. Mary had a trailer. Miss Pauline had a little house. And for the first week and a half after the storm, they lived in their cars. Now they live, like almost everyone else in town, in a tent, which Mary showed me.
我和玛丽·卢·布鲁克斯（Mary Lou Brooks）以及她母亲保琳·戴维森（Pauline Davidson）呆了一会儿。她们都是寡妇，住在同一块三英亩的土地上。玛丽有一辆拖车。保琳女士有一个小房子。在风暴过后的头一周半，她们住在车里。现在她们像镇上的其他人一样住在帐篷里，玛丽给我看了帐篷。
And that basket over there is my clothes, and this is mother's clothes. Got a friend brought us that little thing there, so we can put our nighties and our undies and all in it to keep them separated.
那个篮子是我的衣服，这是妈妈的衣服。有个朋友给了我们那个小东西，这样我们就可以把睡衣、内衣之类的放进去，保持分类存放。
They've got a generator, but they try to use it too much, since gas is so expensive. Mostly they use it at night to run a fan so they can sleep.
她们有一台发电机，但她们不敢多用，因为汽油太贵了。大多数时候她们晚上用它带动风扇好睡觉。
Just close the screen here, and leave this open, and with the fan, it was real cool, you know, in there.
把纱窗关上，留开这个，再加上风扇，里面真的很凉快。
Was it scary at all?
可怕吗？
Yes. I'm not going to tell you no story. It has been scary. I mean, some nights you sleep an hour or two, and some nights you don't sleep any. Because here you are-- you just don't know what's going on. Police come by and told us, wanted to know, do we have guns? And we told them, yes, we did. I've got one and mother's got one. He said, well, I would advise you all to sleep with them close to you. He said, but you all know like I do, once this free stuff's over, he said, there's going to be some bad looting then.
是的。我不会对你撒谎的。一直很可怕。我的意思是，有些晚上你只能睡一两个小时，有些晚上根本睡不着。因为在这里……你根本不知道发生了什么。警察过来告诉我们，问我们有没有枪？我们告诉他们，有的。我有一把，妈妈也有。他说，好吧，我建议你们睡觉时把枪放在身边。他说，但你们也知道，一旦这些免费物资发完了，可能会有严重的抢劫。
Mary is 61. Miss Pauline is 79. She told me later she didn't want to shoot anybody, but she could, if she had to.
玛丽61岁。保琳女士79岁。她后来告诉我她不想射杀任何人，但如果不得不这么做，她也能做到。
To look at her, you'd never, ever guess she'd been camping for the past month. She looks like anyone's fastidiously kempt grandmother. I asked her how in the world she was managing it. Her nails she soaks in Purex laundry soap with a little bleach. She brushes her hair with a Red Cross comb. She's wearing seersucker pedal pushers and a clean white shirt. Someone came by in a truck and let them choose whatever clothes they wanted. A friend from Mobile met her halfway to Pearlington and gave her some new bras. And the day before, her daughter was able to use a washing machine that their Avon lady had hooked up to a clean well in another part of town. Before that, they were washing clothes by hand, using a hose attached to an overflowing well at somebody else's house. They even bathed that way, standing in this guy's yard, soaping themselves through their clothes.
看着她，你永远不会猜到她已经在外面露营了一个月。她看起来像任何人的那种一丝不苟、整洁的老祖母。我问她是怎么做到的。她用含有漂白剂的Purex洗衣液浸泡指甲。她用红十字会的梳子梳头。她穿着泡泡纱裤，穿着干净的白衬衫。有人开着卡车经过，让他们挑选自己想要的衣服。一个来自莫比尔（Mobile）的朋友在中途遇见她，给了她一些新内衣。前一天，她的女儿还能用雅芳（Avon）小姐连接到镇上另一处干净水井上的洗衣机。在那之前，她们是在别人家里用连接到溢水井上的软管洗衣服的。她们甚至那样洗澡，站在那个人的院子里，穿着衣服打肥皂。
They do have a Porta-Potty on their property, but like so many confusing aspects of life in Pearlington right now, there had been some kind of dispute about whether it was supposed to be there.
她们的土地上确实有一个移动厕所，但就像珀林顿目前生活中许多令人困惑的事情一样，关于它是否应该在那儿，发生了一些争执。
But now a toilet, they going to come get it. I called them to come and empty it, because it's stinking. And the lady said, well, thank God! She said, we've been hunting it for a week and a half! I said, well, how did you get it? I said, two men brought it over here in a truck. I don't know who they were. But she says, oh, no. We're going to have to come get it. I said, all right. Come get it.
但现在有人要来把那个马桶拿走。我打电话给他们来清空它，因为它太臭了。那个女士说，噢，谢天谢地！她说，我们已经找了一个半星期了！我说，好吧，你们是怎么弄到它的？我说，两个男的用卡车把它拉到这儿的。我不知道他们是谁。但她说，噢，不。我们必须得来把它拿走。我说，好的。来拿走吧。
Did she tell you why?
她告诉你原因了吗？
Because it was supposed to be at somebody else's place.
因为它是该放在别人家里的。
Wait. This specific toilet?
等等。就是这个特定的马桶？
Yeah.
是的。
But they haven't come, so that's good.
但他们还没来，所以那还不错。
No, they didn't come get it yet, but Lord God, I wish they would. It's been about two weeks now and it's not empty.
不，他们还没来取走，但上帝啊，我真希望他们快点。已经两个星期了，还没清空。
Not for two weeks?
两个星期没清空？
Almost two weeks.
快两个星期了。
So you can't really even use it now, because it's so stinky.
所以你现在甚至不能用了，因为它太臭了。
It's too stinky. I have a bedside toilet, when I had my hip replacement. And we put it back there, and then we can haul it way off back there in the woods and dump it. That's better than nothing, but.
太臭了。我做髋关节置换手术时有一个床边坐便器。我们把它放回后面，然后我们可以把它拖到树林深处倒掉。这比什么都没有要强，但是……
Do you feel like a pioneer?
你感觉自己像个拓荒者吗？
Well, in a way, I guess you would call it that. That's better than homeless. Yeah, that's better than homeless. And that gets to me every once in a while. I have lived almost 80 years to be a homeless.
嗯，在某种程度上，我想你可以这么说。这比无家可归要好。是的，这比无家可归强。偶尔还是会触动我的心。我活了快80岁了，居然成了无家可归的人。
Their days are kind of typical for people here. They spend part of the day cleaning something and part of the day struggling with some form of bureaucracy. Today Mary and Miss Pauline drove about 30 miles round trip to get their mail from a neighboring town.
她们的日子对这里的人来说是典型的。她们花一部分时间清理东西，另一部分时间与某种官僚作风斗争。今天玛丽和保琳女士驱车往返约30英里，去邻镇取邮件。
They're waiting for a FEMA trailer, and they need the electric company to hook up the meter so they can have power ready for the trailer. But to do that, they need to call the electric company, which means driving about eight miles away to get a cell phone signal. Today they spent about two hours by the side of the road, dialing the same number over and over.
她们在等待联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）的拖车，她们需要电力公司连接电表，这样才能为拖车准备好电力。但要做到这一点，她们需要给电力公司打电话，这意味着要开车去大约8英里外的地方找手机信号。今天她们在路边花了大约两个小时，一遍又一遍地拨打同一个号码。
And then there's the problem of insurance. Unlike a lot of people in Pearlington, Miss Pauline actually has homeowner's insurance, but she doesn't have flood insurance. And she said her conversations with the company have been just maddening. They've been arguing about the definition of "flood."
然后还有保险的问题。和珀林顿的许多人不同，保琳女士确实有房主保险，但她没有洪水保险。她说她与保险公司的谈话简直令人发狂。他们一直在争论“洪水”的定义。
They told me, said, we don't pay flood. I said, didn't have no flood. But, no it was a flood. I said, no it wasn't. A flood is when it rains until the water comes up and the lakes and the rivers overflow the bank. That's a flood. And that Gulf didn't jump out here and roll 24 feet of water over my house. The wind did that.
他们告诉我，说，我们不赔洪水。我说，根本没发洪水。但他们说，不，那就是洪水。我说，不，那不是。洪水是指下雨直到水位上涨，湖泊和河流溢出河岸。那才叫洪水。而海湾并没有跳出来，翻涌起24英尺的水淹没我的房子。是风干的。
But so they're saying, we're not going to pay anything?
但他们的意思是，他们什么都不赔？
They said they're going to pay from the waterline up.
他们说他们只赔水位线以上的部分。
But it covered the house.
但水淹没了整栋房子。
Yeah, it covered my house.
是的，它淹没了我的房子。
So that's nothing.
所以那等于是零。
That's the way I'm looking at it.
我就是这么看的。
Certainly one of the most infuriating, soul-crushing things to do is fight with a bureaucracy. And here is literally an entire town doing this, without telephone service. People who have already been through a much less figurative hell.
当然，最令人愤怒和心力交瘁的事情之一就是与官僚机构抗争。而这里确实有一个城镇在没有任何电话服务的情况下做这件事。他们已经经历了不仅仅是比喻意义上的地狱。
I sat in the tree for seven hours, watching all the houses move.
我在树上坐了七个小时，看着所有的房子移动。
Are you kidding me? In the storm, you were there?
你在开玩笑吗？在那场风暴中，你当时在那里？
There was four of us in the tree. Me, a guy by the name of Boogie, a friend of mine, Dale, and then his momma, Peanut. We was up in a big old tree for seven hours with eight dogs.
我们有四个人在树上。我和一个叫Boogie的人，我的朋友戴尔（Dale），还有他的妈妈花生（Peanut）。我们在一棵大树上呆了七个小时，还有八条狗。
This is Dallas, a friend of Miss Pauline's. It took me more than 10 minutes of talking to Dallas-- whose real name is Jean Trammell-- to realize that she was a woman. She's short and kind of square and manly. She's covered in tattoos, and she said so many horrible things happened to her, you kind of marvel that she's still alive.
这是达拉斯（Dallas），保琳女士的朋友。我跟达拉斯——真名叫让·特拉梅尔（Jean Trammell）——谈了10多分钟才意识到她是个女人。她矮矮的，有点方正，很有男子气概。她身上满是纹身，她说她经历了太多可怕的事情，你简直会惊讶她还活着。
She's not from Pearlington, but she's lived here for 13 years, and everyone knows her. She's been checking up on less mobile people on her four-wheeler, which she toured me around on. She can completely understand Miss Pauline's frustration.
她不是珀林顿人，但她在这里住了13年，每个人都认识她。她一直骑着四轮摩托车查看那些行动不便的人，她骑车带我四处参观。她完全理解保琳女士的挫败感。
That's like with me, OK? I'm supposed to be taking Zoloft because I do go into deep depressions at time. Two days ago, I was ready to take a .38 and blow my head off.
这就像我一样，好吧？我应该服用左洛复（Zoloft），因为我有时会陷入深度抑郁。两天前，我准备拿一把.38口径的枪，爆掉自己的头。
Why?
为什么？
Because everything was lost and then we was told FEMA wasn't going to do nothing. And I sat there, day in, day out, day in, day out, for 15 straight days, I didn't go anywhere. Waiting for them. And then we got told last night that they're not coming to the houses anymore.
因为一切都失去了，然后我们被告知联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）什么都不会做。我在那里坐着，一天又一天，一天又一天，整整15天，哪里都没去。等着他们。然后昨晚我们被告知，他们不再来这些房子了。
Apparently this isn't unusual. A mental health counselor I met here told me people typically start to get depressed four to five weeks into a disaster, which is where we are right now.
显然这并不罕见。我在这里遇到的一位心理健康顾问告诉我，人们通常在灾难发生四到五周后开始抑郁，也就是我们现在所处的阶段。
The school, or what's left of it, is where the whole relief effort is based in Pearlington. It's a pretty impressive setup. In the gym, there's a little supermarket of donated stuff. The sheets and pillows are the hottest items. People were allowed to fill two plastic Wal-Mart bags per person, per day, free. Keep in mind that there were no shops in Pearlington before the storm, so this is a big deal.
学校，或者剩下的部分，是珀林顿整个救援工作的基地。这是一个非常令人印象深刻的布置。在体育馆里，有一个小型捐赠超市。床单和枕头是最抢手的商品。每个人每天被允许免费装两个塑料沃尔玛袋子。请记住，在风暴之前珀林顿没有商店，所以这是一件大事。
There are two trailers for showers. One for men, one for women. Although the nice guy who runs them, who came on his own from Oregon, will look the other way if a couple wants to shower together. There's a little clinic staffed by volunteers, and I noticed a box of Zoloft starter kits in there-- some of which Dallas took, thankfully. And one washing machine commandeered from Arkansas.
有两辆拖车用于淋浴。一辆供男人使用，一辆供女人使用。尽管那位来自俄勒冈州、自愿管理这些拖车的好心人，如果有一对夫妇想一起洗澡，也会睁一只眼闭一只眼。有一个小诊所，由志愿者配备，我注意到里面有一箱左洛复入门包——幸好达拉斯拿了一些。还有一台从阿肯色州征用的洗衣机。
The mix of people here is so striking. People who normally would barely speak to each other, never mind become friends, people essentially from different countries, suddenly hanging out.
这里的人员构成非常引人注目。平时几乎不会和对方说话、更不用说成为朋友的人，本质上来自不同国家的人，突然聚在一起。
For example, one day I stopped by at Boogie's, the guy who rode out the storm with Dallas in the tree. Delbert McArthur Junior is his real name. A tough-looking guy with a 6-inch goatee that falls down from his chin in two prongs. A Confederate flag flies on his property. He told the black National Guardsman who came by, that ain't hatred. That's heritage, bro. In his youth, Boogie was known for, as he put it, hurting people.
例如，有一天我拜访了Boogie，那个和达拉斯一起在树上躲过风暴的人。德尔伯特·麦克阿瑟二世（Delbert McArthur Junior）是他的真名。一个看起来很强硬的人，下巴上留着6英寸长的山羊胡，分叉成两股。他的房产上挂着一面邦联旗帜。他告诉路过的一名黑人国民警卫队员，那不是仇恨。那是传统，兄弟。在年轻时，Boogie以他所说的“伤害别人”而闻名。
When I visited, he was drying out his gun collection on a trampoline. About 150 weapons, total.
我去拜访时，他正在蹦床上晾晒他的枪支收藏。总共有大约150件武器。
That one holds 100 rounds.
那一把可以装100发子弹。
And these weren't quite hunting rifles. He's got assault weapons. AK-47s. A banned 12-gauge Street Sweeper that folds in half for easy-- something.
这些可不是什么狩猎步枪。他有突击武器。AK-47。一种禁止使用的12口径“街道清扫者”（Street Sweeper），可以折叠成两半以便轻松……做些什么。
And with him was a group of wholesome-looking church people from Wisconsin, including a fresh-faced college student named Ben.
和他在一起的是一群来自威斯康星州看起来很正直的教会人士，包括一个脸庞清新的大学生，名叫本（Ben）。
What are you doing right now?
你现在在做什么？
I'm fixing to let this gentleman fire this weapon. We're going to walk down by the pond, I'm going to let him fire it. He said he's never fired one.
我正准备让这位绅士射击这个武器。我们准备走到底下的池塘边，我会让他开火。他说他从来没射击过。
Are you from here?
你是这里的人吗？
No, I'm from Eau Claire, Wisconsin.
不，我来自威斯康星州的欧克莱尔（Eau Claire）。
And what are you doing here?
那你在这里做什么？
Hoping to help people out, I guess.
我想，希望能帮大家一把。
How exactly does this help?
这究竟是怎么帮忙的？
Boogie took an AK-47 and walked with Ben to the end of the dirt road to a pond where the family's pigs usually wallow.
Boogie拿着一把AK-47和本一起走到泥路的尽头，来到一个池塘边，那是这家人养猪通常打滚的地方。
[GUNSHOTS]
[枪声]
Ben came to Pearlington with some friends from his church.
本和一些教会朋友一起来到珀林顿。
Nope. It's made for brush fighting.
不是。它是专门为灌木丛战斗设计的。
Like T2, T3, T4, something like that, for like Pull-Ups sizes?
就像T2，T3，T4，类似那种像拉拉队那样的尺码吗？
The next day, back at the school, I saw Ben again. He was in charge of organizing diapers. At the school there's this shelter set up by Christian group based in San Diego and run by a formerly homeless guy from Philadelphia. Another church group from Alabama was cooking all the food in three giant pots, feeding maybe 400 people every day.
第二天，在学校，我又看到了本。他负责组织尿布分发。学校里有一个由总部设在圣地亚哥、由一个曾经无家可归的费城人经营的基督教组织建立的避难所。另一群来自阿拉巴马州的教会组织正在用三个巨大的锅煮所有的食物，每天大约喂养400人。
What is it today?
今天是什么？
It's like chicken pasta. It's got pasta in it, cream of mushroom soup. What else we put, Joseph? This is Dr. Joseph.
类似于鸡肉意大利面。里面有意大利面、奶油蘑菇汤。我们还放了什么，约瑟夫？这是约瑟夫医生。
Hi.
嗨。
He's a cardiologist.
他是一名心脏病专家。
Parmesan cheese. and--
帕玛森芝士，还有——
Wait, you're a cardiologist?
等等，你是心脏病专家？
Yes.
是的。
What? Is like, heart business slow? What are you doing here?
什么？心脏相关的业务这么冷清吗？你在这里做什么？
You start to realize that almost every single person manning the place-- and there are hundreds of them-- is a volunteer from somewhere else. Unpaid, missing work, sweating.
你会开始意识到，这里几乎每一个负责管理的人——有数百人——都是从其他地方来的志愿者。没有报酬，耽误了工作，满头大汗。
Still, I figured there must be some official entity in charge of the whole thing, and I decide to find out who that is. This turns out to be more difficult than you'd think. Pearlington has no town government. No mayor or town council or police department. So I start at what seems like the logical place. I see a guy in a FEMA T-shirt, and I go up to him with my microphone.
尽管如此，我想肯定有某种官方机构负责这一切，我决定找出那是谁。这比你想象的要困难得多。珀林顿没有镇政府。没有镇长、镇议会或警察局。所以我从逻辑上看似合理的地方开始。我看到一个穿着FEMA T恤的人，我拿着麦克风走向他。
Hi. No, no, no, no no, no! FEMA, you cannot run!
嗨。不，不，不，不，不，不！FEMA，你不能跑！
Ask Boss FEMA!
去问FEMA老板！
Who's Boss FEMA?  Are you Boss FEMA?
谁是FEMA老板？你是FEMA老板吗？
No ma'am. No ma'am.
不是女士。不是女士。
He's literally running from me.
他真的在躲着我。
The guy who runs away yells that I should look for a guy named Larry, who is Boss FEMA. It turns out all the guys at the Pearlington distribution site wearing FEMA T-shirts aren't really FEMA. They're firefighters from other states who have been hired by FEMA for 30 days. So they don't know all that much, which sometimes makes people yell at them. And so that's why the guys run away.
那个跑开的家伙喊着让我找一个叫拉里（Larry）的人，他是FEMA老板。结果珀林顿分发中心所有穿着FEMA T恤的人并不是真正的FEMA员工。他们是从其他州被联邦紧急事务管理局聘用30天的消防员。所以他们不太了解情况，这有时让人们对他们大喊大叫。这就是为什么他们会跑开。
I do find Boss Larry, Larry Beachum. He's a firefighter from Missouri, and he signed up for the 30-day FEMA duty. But he rejects the boss label.
我确实找到了老板拉里，拉里·比彻姆（Larry Beachum）。他是一名来自密苏里州的消防员，他签署了30天的FEMA任务。但他拒绝了老板的标签。
Are you the umbrella over all of these organizations that are here? I mean, there must be dozens and dozens.
你是这里所有这些组织的伞状管理机构吗？我的意思是，肯定有几十个。
No. I'm a worker bee. The person, or people, in charge of the operation here is Hancock County, EOC.
不。我是一只工蜂。这里负责运营的人，或者说人们，是汉考克县紧急行动中心（EOC）。
He says there is a lady from Hancock County Emergency Operations and that she's in charge. But it's hard to know what that means, exactly.
他说有一位来自汉考克县紧急行动中心的女士，她是负责人。但很难知道这具体意味着什么。
So the county is the one-- I mean, I guess what I don't quite understand is there are all these different groups, and who's-- so is it her job to coordinate so things don't get doubled up, like two teams don't go out to cut the same tree, or three teams don't feed the same-- you know what I mean?
所以县政府是那个——我的意思是，我想我不太明白的是有所有这些不同的群体，谁在……所以是她的工作来协调，这样事情就不会重复，比如两个团队不会出去砍同一棵树，或者三个团队不会喂食同一个人——你知道我的意思吗？
We do it.
我们来做。
We as who?
我们是指谁？
We coordinate it.
我们协调它。
We as FEMA?
我们是指FEMA？
We as the people that are running this distribution center.
我们是指运营这个分发中心的人。
Pretty soon I find the Hancock County lady, Stacy Pace.
很快我就找到了汉考克县的那位女士，斯泰西·佩斯（Stacy Pace）。
That's a sanitary issue that I thought--
那是一个卫生问题，我想——
She's so busy that she literally doesn't have time to stand still for an interview, so we walk. She's got no office or desk or notebook. Just two cell phones clipped to her belt.
她太忙了，以至于真的没时间停下来接受采访，所以我们边走边谈。她没有办公室、办公桌或笔记本。只有两个别在腰带上的手机。
And so you're from EOC of Hancock County, or--?
所以你是汉考克县EOC的，或者——？
Nope.
不是。
Who are you?
你是谁？
I'm a volunteer from Hancock County.
我是来自汉考克县的一名志愿者。
Oh. So just explain who you are and what you're doing here.
噢。所以解释一下你是谁，在这里做什么。
Whatever I can, basically.
基本上就是我能做的任何事情。
But what is your, like-- when you're not doing this, what do you do?
但你的，像是——当你不做这个的时候，你是做什么的？
I'm director of nursing for Coastal Family.
我是海岸家庭（Coastal Family）的护理主任。
Oh, you're kidding. You don't even work for Emergency Management?
噢，你在开玩笑吧。你甚至不为紧急管理局工作？
No.
不。
Do you have any Emergency Management training?
你有接受过任何紧急管理培训吗？
Ah, other than being a nurse.
啊，除了作为一名护士。
So how did you end up in charge of this?
那你最后是怎么负责起这个的？
Started out fronting the medical clinic, and then just went from there.
从负责医疗诊所开始，然后就从那里开始了。
So Stacy's just another volunteer. She's from the neighboring town and she lost her house, too. She's so neat and organized, one of the guys working there calls her Miss Clean. She says cleanliness is the sign of a good leader.
所以斯泰西只是另一个志愿者。她来自邻镇，也失去了房子。她非常整洁有序，在那里工作的一个人叫她“洁癖小姐”（Miss Clean）。她说清洁是优秀领导者的标志。
Another person who people kept telling me to talk to is the Iceman, who's been loading his Toyota pickup with bags of ice every day and delivering them to people who might not be able to make it to the school. The Iceman is busy-- busy like Stacy-- and he's hard to find. I got some directions that sound more like instructions to a video game.
另一个人人们一直告诉我要去聊聊的是“冰人”（Iceman），他每天用他的丰田皮卡装满冰袋，送给那些可能无法去学校的人。冰人很忙——像斯泰西一样忙——而且很难找到。我得到了一些指示，听起来更像是电子游戏的指令。
You go down around here are the Zuni Indians are. They're the ones that are handing out the ice. You can ask them where the Iceman is. And so you'll see him. He's got kind of a hat on. Looks like a safari hat. And he looks like Crocodile Dundee to me.
你沿着这里走，那边是祖尼印第安人（Zuni Indians）的地方。他们是发冰的人。你可以问问他们冰人在哪。你会看到他的。他戴着那种帽子。看起来像狩猎帽。在我看来他看起来像“鳄鱼邓迪”（Crocodile Dundee）。
The Zuni Hotshots is the name of a group of federal firefighters from New Mexico. They're also paid. Paid to pass out ice.
“祖尼神枪手”（Zuni Hotshots）是一群来自新墨西哥州的联邦消防员的名字。他们也是领薪水的。领薪水来分发冰块。
The way it works is this. Ice has been incredibly important since the hurricane, and a major job of the relief effort is getting it to people. Trucks from all over the country, contracted through FEMA, deliver it to a central command post at a nearby NASA facility. From there it's sent to different drop off points, like this one, where the Zuni Hotshots are, and where the Iceman comes every day.
运作方式是这样的。自飓风以来，冰块一直极其重要，救援工作的一项主要工作就是把它送到人们手中。由联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）承包、来自全国各地的卡车将其运送到附近的NASA设施的中央指挥点。从那里，它被送到不同的降落点，比如祖尼神枪手所在的地方，也是冰人每天来的地方。
A couple hours later, I do meet the Iceman. His real name is Lester Huckabee. He's a paleontologist from Tampa, Florida. He's been here longer than almost any volunteer, so everyone comes to him for help. I go out on an ice run with him.
几个小时后，我确实见到了冰人。他的真名是莱斯特·哈克比（Lester Huckabee）。他是一位来自佛罗里达州坦帕市的古生物学家。他在那里的时间比几乎任何志愿者都长，所以每个人都找他寻求帮助。我跟他一起去送了一趟冰。
Uh, hey! You all need ice here?
呃，嘿！你们这里需要冰吗？
Yes.
需要。
many you need?
你们需要多少？
Lester finally clears things up for me. He tells me there are actually about five people running the Pearlington relief operation.
莱斯特终于把事情向我解释清楚了。他告诉我，实际上大约有五个人在运营珀林顿的救援行动。
When you say five of us, who do you mean?
当你说是我们五个时，你指谁？
Stacy, I. Gosh, a couple people from Colorado. There's mostly volunteers.
斯泰西，我。天哪，还有几个来自科罗拉多州的人。主要是志愿者。
So no one from the government is in those five?
所以这五个人里没有政府的人？
No. We don't have a government here. We're all volunteers. The only government we have is FEMA, and what they do is hand out glorified trailers. Just glorified tents is all the government's doing for them.
没有。我们这儿没有政府。我们全是志愿者。我们唯一的政府就是FEMA，他们所做的就是分发“美化版”的拖车。政府为他们所做的也不过是“美化版”的帐篷而已。
I've seen those FEMA trailers. They're OK.
我见过那些FEMA拖车。它们还行。
They're great if they had electricity and water and sewage.
如果有电、水和污水设施，它们就很棒。
But they do, don't they?  They have a toilet in them.
但它们有，不是吗？它们里面有马桶。
Uh, yeah. But they're not hooked up to nothing. I think that right now there's six FEMA trailers in Pearlington and none of them are hooked up. And how many weeks is it after? 30 days after?
呃，是的。但它们根本没连接任何设施。我想目前珀林顿有六辆FEMA拖车，一辆都没接通。而且现在是几个星期后？30天后？
This is the fifth week. The start of the fifth week.
这是第五个星期。第五个星期的开始。
Fifth week? Good job, FEMA. I'm proud to be American, but I don't have time for horse [BLEEP]. Toby, y'all need some more?
第五个星期？FEMA做得好。我为身为美国人感到骄傲，但我没时间听这些狗屎话。托比（Toby），你们还需要一些吗？
We pass out about 130 bags of ice in 45 minutes. Lester has to go back to get more. He's living in a tent, too, on someone's ruined property, but he's really happy here.
我们在45分钟内分发了大约130袋冰。莱斯特得回去取更多。他也住在帐篷里，在某人被毁的土地上，但他在这里真的很开心。
You were saying you like it here.
你说你喜欢这里。
Yeah. I want to move here.
是的。我想搬到这儿来。
What do you mean, here? To Pearlington?
你的意思是什么，这儿？珀林顿？
Pearlington.
珀林顿。
Are you serious?
你是认真的吗？
I want to help rebuild Pearlington. It's got everything I like. Gators, snakes, fishing, hunting. So it's kind of what I do.
我想帮忙重建珀林顿。它有我喜欢的一切。鳄鱼、蛇、钓鱼、打猎。所以这就是我所做的一切。
But it's destroyed.
但它已经被毁了。
Ah, it can be rebuilt. It's my kind of place. These are perfect people here. They're really special here. Yeah. I'm in love.
啊，它可以被重建。这是我喜欢的地方。这里的人很完美。这里的人真的很特别。是的。我恋爱了。
Boogie, the guy who gave AK-47 lessons to the church people from Wisconsin, feels the same way. He loves this town. He loves it so much that he used to drive six hours to and from work every day rather than relocate. He did try moving away once, for nine months, but it didn't suit him. It was too different. Later he tells me it was to Slidell. Slidell is 12 miles away.
Boogie，那个给威斯康星州教会人士上AK-47射击课的人，也有同样的感觉。他爱这个镇。他太爱它了，以至于他宁愿每天开车六小时往返工作，也不愿搬迁。他确实试过搬走一次，呆了九个月，但不适合他。太不同了。后来他告诉我那是去了斯莱德尔（Slidell）。斯莱德尔距离只有12英里。
Boogie said that since the storm, about half of his friends had left and weren't coming back, but that he just can't leave, even though the town isn't even that great.
Boogie说，自风暴以来，他大约一半的朋友离开了，而且再没回来，但他就是无法离开，尽管这个镇甚至没那么好。
We have heat 10 months out of the year. We have mosquitoes that bite you constantly. I don't know.  It's just-- I've never actually sit and thought about it, never actually tried to figure out what keeps me here. You know? I've always been content. I've never-- well, a couple times I've want to roam, like I said earlier. But other than that, I mean--
我们一年里有10个月很热。我们有不断叮你的蚊子。我不知道。只是……我从来没真正坐下来想过，从没真正想弄清楚是什么让我留在这里。你知道吗？我一直很满足。我从没……嗯，几次我想漫游，就像我刚才说的。但除此之外，我是说——
But do you think that now what's happened, I mean, just looking around-- I mean, I wouldn't even know where to start. It seems so tempting to me just to be like, oh, forget it.
但你认为现在发生了这件事，我是说，看看周围——我是说，我甚至不知道从哪里开始。对我来说，直接说，噢，算了吧，这太诱人了。
I feel even more tied to it now, for some reason. It's hard to explain. It's weird. In my own mind, I think it's weird. Me still wanting to be here even more. Like Dallas tried to get me to go to Slidell to eat dinner and breakfast, and I wouldn't leave. I didn't want to leave.
由于某种原因，我现在觉得和它联系得更紧密了。这很难解释。很奇怪。在我自己看来，我觉得这很奇怪。我甚至更想留在这里。就像达拉斯试图让我去斯莱德尔吃晚餐和早餐，但我没走。我不想离开。
Even just for a meal?
即使只是去吃顿饭？
Just for a meal. Didn't want to leave, for some reason. Especially tied to that tree again, now. I was tied to it when I was a kid. I was hooked up to it.
即使只是吃顿饭。由于某种原因，不想离开。尤其是又和那棵树联系在一起了。我小时候就和它连在一起。我被它“钩”住了。
You used to climb it?
你以前常爬它？
All the time. Sleep in it.
一直。在上面睡觉。
He's talking about the tree where they all survived the storm. That's another thing that's happened. He's become close to Dallas. He used to think he hated her. I asked her about that, about what it was like for a gay woman to move onto that street 13 years ago. She said after she first moved in, her neighbors set fire to her truck and poisoned a couple of her dogs and threw trash in her yard. After she confronted them, things got better. Since the storm, she's talked to her neighbors more than ever before.
他指的是那棵他们躲过风暴的大树。这也发生了变化。他已经和达拉斯变得亲密起来。他以前以为他恨她。我问过她那件事，一个女同性恋13年前搬到那条街上是什么感觉。她说刚搬进来时，邻居烧了她的卡车，毒死了她几条狗，还把垃圾扔在她的院子里。在她和他们对质后，事情变好了。自风暴以来，她和邻居的交谈比以往任何时候都多。
Since all this has happened, me and Boogie's got real close with me. And when they first brought the campers there, I slept in one of the campers for two nights, and then his cousin came in, so I left. Because it was actually his cousin's camper. And he kept telling me, why don't you go to sleep in there and I'll sleep out here? And I said, no. You go ahead and sleep in there. That's your family. You stay there. I said, I'll be all right.
自从这一切发生后，我和Boogie变得很亲近。他们第一次把露营车带到那里时，我在其中一辆车里睡了两晚，然后他堂兄来了，我就离开了。因为那实际上是他堂兄的露营车。他一直对我说，你为什么不去那里睡，我在外面睡？我说，不。你进去睡吧。那是你的家人。你留在那儿。我说，我会没事的。
Well, he come by later on. Got him a drink out the ice chest-- even though they got ice chests over there. And he tells me, "Goodnight." And I went "OK, goodnight." And then he said something else, and I never did hear what he said. Well, the next day I ask him, I said, I know you said goodnight, but I know you said something else. What did you say? Oh. I said, "I love you." And I went, "OK. Love you too."
好吧，他后来过来了。从冰柜里拿了杯喝的——尽管他们在那边有冰柜。他对我说，“晚安。”我回了一句，“好的，晚安。”然后他又说了些什么，我从来没听清他说什么。好吧，第二天我问他，我说，我知道你说晚安，但我知道你还说了别的。你说了什么？噢。我说，“我爱你。”我说，“好的，我也爱你。”
Even though people are coming together in this unprecedented way, looking around Pearlington, it's really hard to imagine that the town will survive. There's already a song about that by Miss Mississippi. It sounds like a death knell.
尽管人们以前所未有的方式团结在一起，但看看珀林顿周围，真的很难想象这个镇能活下来。密西西比小姐（Miss Mississippi）已经有一首关于那首歌了。听起来像丧钟。
[MUSIC – "PEARLINGTON'S PRAYER" BY MISS MISSISSIPPI]
[音乐 - 密西西比小姐的《珀林顿的祈祷》]
Bring back Pearlington. Pearlington. Save Pearlington.
带回珀林顿。珀林顿。拯救珀林顿。
The school, the only public building in town, probably won't get rebuilt, which means little kids will have to be bussed to another town. A good number of people probably won't come back at all, and the ones who are staying are suddenly so poor.
学校，镇上唯一的公共建筑，可能不会被重建，这意味着小孩将不得不被送往另一个镇。很多人可能根本不会回来，而留下来的人突然变得如此贫穷。
Miss Pauline, who finally got her FEMA trailer two days after I left, thinks she'll eventually buy it and live the rest of her life in it. You get the feeling that will be the only choice for a lot of people here.
保琳女士在我离开两天后终于拿到了她的FEMA拖车，她认为她最终会买下它并在里面度过余生。你会觉得那对这里很多人来说是唯一的选择。
[SUBJECT] Pearlington is my name, you, live in all the nation's news, hurricane did her abuse, and now. My train tracks are all twisted and my houses have been lifted and security was shifted by the storm.
[主题] 珀林顿是我的名字，你，活在所有全国新闻里，飓风对她滥用，而现在。我的火车轨道全扭曲了，我的房子被抬高了，安全被风暴转移了。
Sarah Koenig reported that story.
莎拉·柯尼格报道了这个故事。
Coming up-- one teenager's guide to the best and worst MREs. Could be handy when your town gets hit by a hurricane. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来——一个青少年的MRE（即食口粮）最佳和最差指南。当你的城镇遭到飓风袭击时，这可能会很方便。稍后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program-- "Back from the Dead." Stories of people and towns that have come back from the brink. Or are trying to come back, anyway.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目——“死里逃生”。关于那些从边缘归来，或至少试图回归的人和城镇的故事。
We've arrived at act three of our show. Act Three. "Friday Night Floodlights."
我们已经到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“周五晚上的泛光灯”。
About 15 miles from Pearlington, the town we just heard about in act two, are the towns of Waveland and Bay St. Louis. Waveland was pretty much wiped out in the hurricane. The majority of homes and businesses were destroyed or severely damaged. Bay St. Louis fared only a little better. Even now, a month later, you can't drink the water out of the faucet. Some people still don't have electricity. Not really the kind of place you'd expect to find a thriving high school football scene. One of our producers, Lisa Pollak, says, that's coming back.
距离第二幕提到的珀林顿大约15英里，是韦弗兰（Waveland）和圣路易斯湾（Bay St. Louis）镇。韦弗兰在飓风中几乎被摧毁。大多数房屋和企业被破坏或严重受损。圣路易斯湾的情况只稍微好一点。即使现在，一个月后，你不能喝水龙头里的水。有些人仍然没有电。这不是你期望找到一个蓬勃发展的高中橄榄球场景的地方。我们的制片人之一丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）说，这一切正在回归。
The Bay High Tigers played their first game of the season on the Friday before Katrina. They beat Hancock High, 30-14. After the storm, the joke was that they'd gone undefeated. Everyone figured the season was over. Players were homeless. The high school was closed.
湾高中（Bay High）老虎队在卡特里娜飓风前的那个周五打了赛季第一场比赛。他们以30比14击败了汉考克高中。风暴过后，笑话是他们不败了。每个人都以为赛季结束了。球员们无家可归。高中关闭了。
But just days after the hurricane, the Bay High coach, Brenan Compretta, started hearing from his players. They wanted to play football. They called his cell and sent text messages. They stopped him on the street. They wanted to play football. They wanted something that reminded them of what life was before.
但在飓风后的几天里，湾高中教练布伦南·康普雷塔（Brenan Compretta）开始收到球员们的来信。他们想打橄榄球。他们打他的手机，发短信。他们在街上拦住他。他们想打橄榄球。他们想要一些提醒他们生活曾经是什么样子的东西。
The thing that a lot of them were saying is it only takes 11 men to play, and no matter how many they had, they wanted to do this. That was the only thing that they had to look forward to, you know?
很多人都在说的一点是，只要11个人就能打，无论有多少人，他们都想做这件事。那是他们唯一能期待的事情，你懂吗？
You wouldn't stage a school play without a school, but football is different. Here, anyway. In Bay St. Louis, game day starts at 6:30 AM with the team breakfast at a church. Newspaper stories about the game are posted on the wall at school. In the afternoon, drummers from the band march through the hallways just before the pep rally. Strangers in town stop players to talk about that week's game. So even though school won't start again until November, the coach called a meeting to try to restart the team.
你不会在没有学校的情况下安排校园戏剧，但橄榄球不同。至少在这里是这样。在圣路易斯湾，比赛日从早上6:30的教会球队早餐开始。关于比赛的报纸报道张贴在学校墙上。下午，乐队的鼓手在激励集会前游行穿过走廊。镇上的陌生人会拦住球员谈论当周的比赛。所以即使学校要到11月才重新开学，教练也召集了一次会议，试图重启球队。
There were some challenges. Only 19 players showed up of the 70 who were on the team. They couldn't use their practice field since National Guardsmen were camping there. Their field house was destroyed and most of their equipment. And as for their uniforms--
有一些挑战。原本70人的球队只来了19个球员。他们不能使用练习场地，因为国民警卫队在那里扎营。他们的更衣室被毁了，大部分装备也没了。至于他们的制服——
We pulled up, a few days after the storm. They had people running around in our jerseys and cleats, and throwing balls around. And I guess it was fathers and sons or whatever.
风暴过后几天我们停下来。他们有人穿着我们的球衣和球鞋跑来跑去，还在扔球。我想那是父子什么的。
Wait, so you saw people wearing your guys' football jerseys just as, like, replacement clothes?
等等，所以你看到人们穿着你们橄榄球队的球衣只是作为……替换衣服？
Right, exactly. And you know, considering the circumstances, I didn't get really upset about it. It was like, well, I guess if they need some clothes, they can go ahead and take them, you know?
对，没错。而且你知道，考虑到当时的情况，我并没有因此真正生气。这就像是，好吧，我想如果他们需要一些衣服，他们可以拿去，你知道吗？
They're saying-- there's a possibility-- they're saying it's probably going to be one of the most packed games we've played, ever.
他们说——有可能——他们说这可能是我们打过的最爆满的比赛之一，史无前例。
It's game day-- the Tigers' very first game since Hurricane Katrina, one month after the storm. And I've flown to Mississippi, where Tyler Brush, the team's quarterback, is showing me around. There's not a lot to see. Just huge piles of wreckage. And near the beach, mile after mile of empty spaces where houses and buildings used to be.
今天是比赛日——老虎队自卡特里娜飓风以来的第一场比赛，风暴发生一个月后。我已经飞到了密西西比，球队的四分卫泰勒·布拉什（Tyler Brush）正带我参观。没什么可看的。只有巨大的残骸堆。靠近海滩的地方，曾经是房子和建筑物的地方现在空无一物。
After the hurricane Tyler's family left for a while. Moved to Florida, to a town where they used to live. They got a nice house and Tyler began high school there. He was practicing with their football squad. He was going to be a starter there, too. But then Coach Compretta called. Tyler says coming back here was a hard choice.
飓风过后，泰勒一家离开了一段时间。搬到了佛罗里达，他们以前住过的一个镇。他们有了一栋漂亮的房子，泰勒在那里开始了高中生活。他正和那里的橄榄球队练习。他本来也要在那里担任首发。但后来康普雷塔教练打了电话。泰勒说回到这里是一个艰难的选择。
My dad, he originally didn't want me to come back. I mean, he was pretty much against it. But he decided-- he said that it was my decision. I mean, I had to think about it a lot.
我爸爸，他最初不想让我回来。我是说，他基本上是反对的。但他决定——他说这是我的决定。我是说，我必须想很多。
I was nervous about coming back. I recognize the situation. I knew I was taking the chance, if I came back here, college teams might not see me play. But I felt that I still needed to come back, though, for whoever did come back.
我对自己回来感到紧张。我认识到这种情况。我知道我冒了险，如果我回到这里，大学球队可能看不到我比赛。但我感觉我仍然需要回来，为了任何回来的人。
As quarterback, he didn't want to let the team down. So now his family is living 15 miles away in Diamond Head, and two of the team's other players, whose families didn't return, are living with them, too.
作为四分卫，他不想让球队失望。所以现在他一家住在15英里外的钻石角（Diamond Head），球队的其他两名家庭没回来的球员也住他们家。
This is a strange place to be a kid right now. With no school, they spend their days doing cleanup work. Hauling out sheet rock and moving trees and debris. It's bleak and boring. Their favorite hangouts are gone. Football is one of the few things they have left.
现在做一个孩子是一个奇怪的地方。没有学校，他们整天做清理工作。搬运石膏板，移动树木和残骸。既凄凉又无聊。他们最喜欢的聚会点都不见了。橄榄球是他们剩下的为数不多的几样东西之一。
We're actually pulling up to my house now. This is pretty much nothing left of my house. There's some stairs right here-- were right here, leading up to the house. They're completely gone.
我们现在正开向我家。我家基本上什么都没剩下。这里有一些楼梯——就在这里，通往房子的。它们完全消失了。
Literally all we are looking at are the wooden stilts that held up the house and the foundation, which looks like it was lifted up from the ground. And I mean, there isn't even like stuff around. Like furniture or clothes, or-- where did all the stuff go?
我们实际上看到的是支撑房子的木柱和地基，看起来像是从地面上被抬起来的。我的意思是，周围甚至没有东西。比如家具或衣服，或者……东西都去哪了？
I guess water just washed them up that way. Wiped out. There's nothing left.
我猜水把它们冲走了。全毁了。什么都没剩下。
Does anybody in here need pants? You need pants, come with me.
这里有人需要裤子吗？需要裤子，跟我来。
Over at the football field, the new uniforms arrive just in time-- a gift from a man in North Carolina-- and the kids line up while the coaches open the boxes. The new jerseys are blue and white, not blue and gold, the school colors, but no one seems to care.
在橄榄球场，新制服刚好及时送达——来自北卡罗来纳州一个人的礼物——孩子们在教练打开盒子时排成一行。新球衣是蓝色和白色的，不是学校颜色的蓝和金，但似乎没人介意。
Hold on-- hey, man. We're not getting picky here. Just relax, buddy. What do you need?
等等——嘿，老兄。我们在这里不挑剔。放松，伙计。你需要什么？
This isn't the team it used to be. Over half the Tigers still haven't come back, so the coaches have filled out the roster with some new recruits. A few seniors who have never played football, some freshmen from the school's ninth grade team, two guys from the Tigers' archrival, Saint Stanislaus-- they cancelled their season-- and to cap it all off, Bad News Bears style, some scared-looking seventh and eighth graders from the junior high. In all, it's still just 29 players-- a long way from 70.
这不是以前的那支球队了。超过一半的老虎队球员还没回来，所以教练组用一些新招募的人充实了名单。几个从未打过球的高年级学生，一些来自学校九年级球队的新生，两个来自老虎队死对头圣斯坦尼斯劳斯（Saint Stanislaus）的球员——他们取消了赛季——最后，为了锦上添花，像电影《少棒闯天下》（Bad News Bears）风格那样，一些看起来很害怕的初中七八年级学生。总之，总共只有29名球员——距离70人差得远。
Some of these kids are all but homeless, sleeping on other families' couches and floors. One linebacker is living in a camper, alone, his parents hours away. All so he can play football.
其中一些孩子几乎无家可归，睡在别人的沙发和地板上。一个线卫独自住在拖车里，他父母在几小时外。一切都是为了能打橄榄球。
With everything these kids have been dealing with and everything they've seen, they seem genuinely relieved and excited to be here today, putting on jerseys and lacing up cleats.
面对这些孩子一直在处理的一切以及他们所看到的一切，他们今天看起来真的很欣慰和兴奋能来到这里，穿上球衣并系上球鞋。
Everybody's just anxious to play again, to get things back to normal.
每个人都急于再次打球，让一切回到正常状态。
That's Trevor Adams, a senior tight end. And for him, getting things back to normal means pretty much one thing.
那是特雷弗·亚当斯（Trevor Adams），一名高年级近端锋。对他来说，让事情回到正常状态基本上意味着一件事。
I love hitting people. That's-- I mean, there no better feeling in the world, just unloading on somebody. I mean, even now, dealing with all this, you have an extra feel of warmth. You get just that exciting feeling about, you know, hitting somebody, or you-- there's no-- you can't explain it.
我喜欢撞人。那是——我的意思是，世界上没有比那更好的感觉了，直接卸下力量撞在某人身上。我是说，即使是现在，处理所有这些事情，你也会有一种额外的温暖感。你会得到那种兴奋的感觉，你知道，撞击某人，或者你——没有——你无法解释它。
Equally excited is Brandt, a tenth grader. I think Brandt might be one of the happiest kids I've ever met. He doesn't stop beaming, even when he's talking about swimming through his flooded kitchen, or living for weeks without plumbing or power. He moved to Texas to stay with a relative for a while, but didn't stay long.
同样兴奋的是布兰特（Brandt），一个十年级的学生。我想布兰特可能是我见过的最快乐的孩子之一。他不停地绽放笑容，即使在他谈论游泳穿过被淹的厨房，或者在没有管道或电力的情况下生活数周时。他搬到德克萨斯州和亲戚呆了一段时间，但没呆多久。
Texas was great.  Everybody was real kind. Like scary kind. It was just like-- have you ever seen The Stepford Wives? How everything's perfect? That's how it was. They were all like, hi, how are you doing? Can I get you anything? Clothes? Food? And I'm like, I'm fine, ma'am.
德克萨斯很好。每个人都真的很友善。像是吓人的那种友善。这就像是——你看过《复制娇妻》（The Stepford Wives）吗？一切都很完美？就是那样。他们都像是，嗨，你好吗？我能为你拿点什么吗？衣服？食物？我说，我很好，女士。
So does this feel like a normal couple hours before a game, or does it feel different.
所以这感觉像是比赛前正常的一两个小时，还是感觉不同？
Way different.
太不同了。
One thing I'm going to miss before the game is the pregame meals. We don't have that here. Them pregame meals were good. All you can eat.
比赛前我会想念的一件事是赛前餐。我们这里没有。那些赛前餐很好吃。管够。
What kind of food?
什么食物？
Ah. Baked chicken with all these spices on it. Just so good.
啊。烤鸡，上面加了所有这些香料。真好吃。
You're making me hungry.
你让我饿了。
That was like a month ago.
那是一个月前的事了。
So you've stayed here this whole time. What's there been to eat for you?
所以你一直呆在这里。这期间你吃什么？
Three meals a day, MREs.
一日三餐，MRE。
So what's an MRE taste like?
所以MRE是什么味道？
I'll tell you what. Meal number 20 and meal number 22. 20 is spaghetti and 22 is jambalaya. The best. I told my momma she should step it up, because that stuff is-- I'm going to just start getting MREs just regular.
我告诉你。第20号餐和第22号餐。20号是意大利面，22号是什锦饭（jambalaya）。最好吃的。我告诉我妈她应该改进一下，因为那东西——我打算直接开始正常吃MRE了。
All right. Hey, guys. Everybody right here, where these guys are, get down, you can take a knee or something. Let's go. Real quick. You can sit down or take a knee, either one.
好了。嘿，伙计们。所有人到这儿，这些人在的地方，蹲下，或者跪下什么的。走吧。快点。你可以坐下或者跪下，随便哪种。
It's late afternoon now, about an hour before the game. Everybody gathers around Coach Compretta, and he urges them to think about the past month when they get on the field tonight.
现在是傍晚，离比赛还有一个小时。每个人都聚集在康普雷塔教练周围，他催促他们在今晚进入球场时想想过去的一个月。
Everything you have inside of you, let it out. All the aggravation, the frustration, having to get up and do all the junk you do every day because of this hurricane-- let it all out right here. Play for your community. That's why you're here, OK? Some people can't be here. Play for the guys who can't be here, too. Play for Bay St. Louis and Waveland.
你内心拥有的一切，释放出来。所有的愤怒、挫折，因为这场飓风每天必须起床做所有那些琐事——在这里全部释放出来。为你的社区打球。这就是你在这里的原因，好吗？有些人不能在这里。也为那些不能在这里的伙计们打球。为圣路易斯湾和韦弗兰打球。
Does anybody have any questions about anything? Offense, defense, special teams, what? What?
有人对任何事有疑问吗？进攻，防守，特勤组，什么？什么？
I love everybody.
我爱每个人。
We love you too, Cal.
我们也爱你，卡尔（Cal）。
Love you too, Cal.
也爱你，卡尔。
Of course, there's only so much love one football team can take. An hour later, as the team gets ready to run onto the field, the coach has this to say.
当然，一支橄榄球队能承受的爱是有限的。一小时后，当球队准备跑向球场时，教练说了这些话。
So forget all the kindness and niceness right now, all that junk. Go out there and get after their behinds. Do you understand me?
所以现在忘了所有的友善和温柔，所有那些琐事。出去狠狠教训他们。你们听明白了吗？
Yes sir!
听明白了！
Now, we do want to win the football game, OK? Everybody touch somebody. Let's go.
现在，我们想要赢得这场橄榄球比赛，好吗？每个人都触碰下身边的人。走吧。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[听不清]
Ladies and gentlemen, the Bay High Tigers!
女士们先生们，湾高中老虎队！
It's kind of hard to believe that out of the ruins of this town, just down the street from gutted houses and buildings, this thing has appeared, this movie-set perfect football game.
很难相信在这个小镇的废墟中，离被掏空的房子和建筑物几条街的地方，出现了这一幕，这一幕就像电影布景般完美的橄榄球赛。
It's dusk now, with a pinkish sky. And under the stadium lights, everything's kind of glowing, and everyone showed up to play their part. The cheerleaders, the PA announcer, the marching band, or what's left of it. A single kid with a snare drum, standing in the bleachers.
现在是黄昏，天空粉红。在体育场的灯光下，一切都在发光，每个人都出现扮演自己的角色。啦啦队员、广播员、游行乐队，或者剩下的部分。一个带着小军鼓的孩子，站在看台上。
Please join me in singing the national anthem.
请和我一起唱国歌。
The opposing team, the Long Beach Bearcats, line up on the other side of the field. The moment I see them, my heart sinks a little. Not only are there twice as many of them, they just look so determined. Assistant Coach Keith sizes them up this way.
对方球队，长滩猎豹队（Long Beach Bearcats），排在球场的另一边。看到他们的那一刻，我的心沉了一点。不仅他们人数是我们的两倍，他们看起来也如此坚定。助理教练基思（Keith）这样评估他们。
Ah. Big They came here on three buses. We need a minivan, you know? A big difference. And they don't have junior high kids out there, and we do.
啊。很大。他们乘三辆巴士来到这里。我们需要一辆小型货车，你知道吗？巨大的差异。而且他们没有初中生在场上，我们有。
Not even the quarterback's father expects the Tigers to win tonight. They're missing so many guys that they'll have to play their good players twice as much. Their starters will play offense and defense. Guys will wear out.
甚至连四分卫的父亲都不指望老虎队今晚赢。他们缺了太多人，他们不得不让好球员多上一倍的时间。他们的首发将同时打进攻和防守。伙计们会累垮的。
Doing the kicking for the Bearcats, Chip Vonderbruegge.
为猎豹队踢球的是奇普·冯德布鲁格（Chip Vonderbruegge）。
The Tigers get off to a great start. The first time they get the ball, they go in a drive that lasts half the first quarter and ends with a touchdown on a six yard run by Robert Labat. I watch Tyler pass the ball off to Robert, knowing that Tyler pretty much moved back to town for this moment, and that Robert, who is living with them, separated from his own family, did too.
老虎队有了一个伟大的开始。他们第一次拿到球，就进行了一次持续了半节的推进，以罗伯特·拉巴特（Robert Labat）的6码冲球达阵告终。我看着泰勒把球传给罗伯特，知道泰勒搬回这里几乎就是为了这一刻，而和他们住在一起、与家人分离的罗伯特也是如此。
Get out there! Go, go, go! Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
出去！跑，跑，跑，跑，跑，跑，跑，跑。
Touchdown. TIgers on the board!
达阵。老虎队得分！
Fight, fight! Here we go, go!
加油，加油！这就对了，走！
On the sidelines, eight Tiger cheerleaders are jumping around. It's more than half the squad. One tells me her uniform was the first thing she packed when her family evacuated. When the girls aren't cheering, they're consulting this big, elaborate chart they've set up in front of the bleachers. Celeste, the captain, explains.
边线上，八名老虎队啦啦队员在蹦蹦跳跳。这已经是半个队伍了。一个人告诉我，她的制服是她家人撤离时她打包的第一件东西。女孩们不跳啦啦操时，她们正在研究她们在看台前设立的一张巨大、复杂的表格。队长塞莱斯特（Celeste）解释说。
This is our cheer list, and we have 63 cheers on it. And every year we just take it and we add more to it.
这是我们的加油列表，上面有63个加油口号。每年我们都把它拿出来并增加更多。
OK. So like, what's 36?
OK。那么，36是什么？
36 is G-O, go Tigers go.
36是G-O，加油老虎加油。
And then what's 37?
那37是什么？
37 is G-O, go, go! G-O, go.
37是G-O，加油，加油！G-O，加油。
And what's 28?
那28是什么？
Go, go, G-O. Go, Tigers, go.
加油，加油，G-O。加油，老虎，加油。
There's some similarity.
有些相似之处。
Yes, they're very.
是的，非常。
The coaches are scurrying up and down the field, improvising to fill in for the key players they don't have, swapping kids in and out. Brandt, the MRE kid, is getting trounced out there, so the coach pulls him aside.
教练们在球场上跑来跑去，即兴发挥以填补他们没有的关键球员，换下孩子。布兰特，那个吃MRE的孩子，在外面被打得很惨，所以教练把他拉到一边。
Hey Brandt, not bad baby, not bad baby. Going to make a change, put somebody in there with a little more behind on him, OK?
嘿布兰特，不错宝贝，不错宝贝。要做个改变，换个后面更有力量的人进去，好吗？
I got manhandled up here.
我在上面被粗暴对待了。
I know, we saw that.
我知道，我们看到了。
But the rookie players come through with some surprises. For instance, at the very same moment that the coaches are grumbling to themselves about where exactly freshman Allan Villalta is heading on the field, Villalta recovers a fumble.
但新秀球员带来了一些惊喜。例如，就在教练们嘟囔着新生艾伦·维拉尔塔（Allan Villalta）究竟在球场上往哪里跑的时候，维拉尔塔抢到了一个掉球。
Oh God, Villalta is on the [BLEEP]. Oh damn, he just made a play! He just made a damn play.
噢天哪，维拉尔塔在……上。噢该死，他刚才做了一个漂亮的动作！他刚才做了一个该死的漂亮的动作。
By the end of the first half, it's Tigers 7, Bearcats 6.
到半场结束时，老虎队7比6领先猎豹队。
Good job, Walt, that a boy. Good job.
干得好，沃尔特（Walt），好样的。干得好。
The home bleachers are pretty packed by now. And the thing I realize when I start talking to people is that this is the first time this town has gotten together since the hurricane. One of the first people I meet, Gary Yarborough, doesn't even have a kid on the team.
主场看台现在相当拥挤。当我开始和人们交谈时，我意识到这是自飓风以来这个镇第一次聚在一起。我遇到的第一个人之一，加里·亚伯勒（Gary Yarborough），甚至没有孩子在这支球队里。
I'm just out here, just trying to see who's still here, who's still in town, and visit with the other folks. And see how everybody's handling everything and dealing with everything.
我只是来这里，试图看看谁还在，谁还在镇上，和大家伙儿聊聊天。看看每个人是怎么应对一切，处理一切的。
Is this the first time you're seeing a lot of folks in a while?
这是你很久以来第一次看到这么多人吗？
Yeah, some of them, yeah. Because you know, with the curfews and nothing open in town, there's really no place to go to see anybody.
是的，有些人，是。因为你知道，有宵禁，镇上什么都没开，真的没地方聚会看谁。
As I walk through the stands, the one thing people keep telling me is what a normal night this is, what a relief it is to do something normal again. But talk to anyone for more than a couple minutes, and what you hear next is just how far from normal everything is. They're worried about flood insurance and FEMA trailers and whether they'll have jobs. I asked one man, the Booster Club president, what the highlight of the game is so far, and he nearly starts to cry.
当我走过看台时，人们一直告诉我的唯一一件事是这是一个多么正常的夜晚，能再次做一些正常的事情是一种解脱。但只要和任何人聊上几分钟，你接下来听到的就是一切离正常有多远。他们担心洪水保险、FEMA拖车以及他们是否会有工作。我问一个人，后援会会长，到目前为止比赛的亮点是什么，他几乎开始哭泣。
Down on the field, the Tigers are playing better than anyone had expected. Going into the fourth quarter, the score is 21-6, Tigers comfortably leading. But then, in the last five minutes of the game, everything falls apart. The Bearcats' star player, Tramaine Brock, rushes for a touchdown. They miss the extra point, so it's 21-12. Two minutes later, with just three minutes left in the game, Brock sprints 55 years to the end zone as the Tiger coaches watch helplessly.
在球场上，老虎队打得比任何人预期的都要好。进入第四节，比分是21比6，老虎队领先。但随后，在比赛最后五分钟，一切都崩溃了。猎豹队的明星球员特雷曼·布罗克（Tramaine Brock）冲出达阵。他们错过了额外得分，所以是21比12。两分钟后，比赛只剩三分钟时，布罗克冲刺55码进入达阵区，老虎队教练无助地看着。
That's it. He's gone. [BLEEP] He's gone. Dang it.
就是这样。他走了。该死。他走了。可恶。
It's a two point game now, 21-19. The Tigers are still waiting, but Long Beach has the momentum, and they only need a field goal to win. The Tigers are completely exhausted. Many have been on the field the entire game. The kicker is limping. Allan Villalta, the ninth grader who made that great play, is on the sidelines with an injured knee.
现在是两分差距了，21比19。老虎队还在等待，但长滩队士气正盛，他们只需要一个射门就能赢。老虎队精疲力竭。许多人在整个比赛中都在场上。踢球的人一瘸一拐。那个做出漂亮动作的新生艾伦·维拉尔塔，因为膝盖受伤坐在边线上。
The Tigers get the ball back, their last possession, but they can't even manage a first down. They punt it away, and there's still plenty of time for Long Beach to score.
老虎队拿回了球，最后一次进攻，但他们甚至没能拿到首攻。他们弃踢了，长滩队还有充足的时间得分。
Everything you've got, right now!
拿出你拥有的一切，就在现在！
Be ready to drive!
准备好进攻！
The Bearcats start to drive again. They cross the 50 yard line into Bay High territory. The clock is running down. Coaches are screaming.
猎豹队再次开始推进。他们越过50码线，进入湾高中领地。时间在流逝。教练在尖叫。
Jason, be ready to drop. Here we go!  Here we go!
杰森（Jason），准备好防守。走吧！走吧！
The place is going nuts.
现场陷入疯狂。
Bay High! Bay High!
湾高中！湾高中！
I can honestly say this is the only football game I've ever been to where it really did seem to matter who won. Earlier I felt bad taking sides against the Bearcats. Their town was hit by the hurricane, too. But now I don't know what I'll do if the Tigers lose. Their town was hit harder. They're the underdogs. They have to win.
我可以诚实地说，这是我去过的唯一一场橄榄球赛，谁赢真的看起来非常重要。早些时候我觉得反对猎豹队感觉很不好。他们的镇也受到了飓风袭击。但现在如果老虎队输了，我不知道我会做什么。他们的镇受灾更严重。他们是弱势一方。他们必须赢。
And then, they do. They stop the Bearcats. It's over.
然后，他们做到了。他们挡住了猎豹队。结束了。
The clock runs out and the place explodes. 21-19 Tigers. It's every corny sports movie come to life. People streaming on the field, hugging, players sprawled on the ground. All these people in this wrecked town ecstatic over a football game. Assistant coach Jeremy Turcotte.
比赛时间结束，现场爆炸了。老虎队21比19赢了。这是每一部俗气的运动电影照进现实。人们涌上球场，拥抱，球员瘫倒在地上。这个被毁小镇上的所有这些人，为一个橄榄球比赛狂喜。助理教练杰里米·图尔科特（Jeremy Turcotte）。
I think next to getting married and having my baby, that's about the most amazing thing I've ever seen in my life.
我想除了结婚和生孩子，那是我一生中见过的最神奇的事情。
Hey guys, listen up.  I'm going to let you go. I know we got to get home.
嘿伙计们，听好了。我要让你们走了。我知道我们要回家。
Coach Compretta.
康普雷塔教练。
Never been more proud, OK? In my coaching career. Never been more proud of a group of guys in my life than right now. I love you guys. I love you guys. Take tomorrow off. See you on Wednesday, 3:30. Be here for 3:30, OK? Everybody touch somebody. Great job, fellows. Great job, fellows.
从来没这么骄傲过，好吗？在我教练生涯中。我一生中从来没对一群伙计像现在这样骄傲。我爱你们。我爱你们。明天休假。周三3点半见。3点半一定要到，好吗？每个人触碰身边的人。干得好，伙计们。干得好，伙计们。
Break it down, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] win.
解散，[听不清] 赢。
Bay St. Louis of Hancock County is still under a curfew, ladies and gentlemen. After the game, you'll need to go home as soon as possible.
圣路易斯湾和汉考克县仍然处于宵禁中，女士们先生们。比赛后，你需要尽快回家。
And just like that, the place clears out. A half hour later, the only people left are the coaches, still reliving the game. Luke, one of the assistants, is on the cell phone with his brother in Alabama.
就这样，现场的人群散去了。半小时后，剩下的人只有教练，还在回味这场比赛。卢克（Luke），助理教练之一，正在手机上和他在阿拉巴马州的兄弟通话。
They had the ball with about a minute and a half left, driving with no time outs, and we sacked them with no time left. But I just wanted to call and tell you that, man. I'll call you tomorrow sometime. I just wanted to holler at you real quick. I love you, bro. Bye.
他们还剩一分半钟时有球，在没暂停的情况下推进，我们就在时间耗尽前擒抱了他们。但我只是想打个电话告诉你那个，伙计。明天什么时候再打给你。我只是想很快地吼你一下。爱你，兄弟。再见。
Of all the coaches I met here, Luke seemed the most discouraged about everything. He'd lost his house. He sounded disheartened. In the morning, he told me that when his contract is up in May, he'll probably leave here. But now his mood is different.
在所有我遇到的教练中，卢克对一切似乎最气馁。他失去了房子。他听起来很沮丧。早上他告诉我，明年5月合同时，他可能会离开这里。但现在他的心情不同了。
And you know, we play next Friday night here, and you know, it's not like the town's going to be back to normal next Friday night. So I mean, they're still going to not have anything to do, they're still going to be a curfew. And you know, I mean, this just starts it. I mean, if you lose tonight, it's like, you know what? You go home and you're sitting in a trailer and you have no AC and you lost a football game. But you know, it's a little easier to go home and sit in a trailer with no AC when you just won a football game that nobody gave you a chance to win.
你知道，下周五晚上我们在这里打球，你知道，并不意味着下周五晚上小镇就会恢复正常。所以我的意思是，他们仍然会没事可做，仍然会有宵禁。而且你知道，我的意思是，这只是开始。我的意思是，如果你今晚输了，就像是，你知道吗？你回家坐在拖车里，没有空调，还输了一场橄榄球比赛。但你知道，当你赢了一场没人认为你能赢的橄榄球赛时，回家坐在没有空调的拖车里会容易一点。
Before coming to Bay St. Louis, I felt the way I think a lot of us feel when we see these places on TV. I didn't understand how you go back to a town like that, to all that loss, and live there in the middle of it. What are you going back there for? And how do you even begin to get over it?
在来到圣路易斯湾之前，我感觉就像我们许多人在电视上看到这些地方时的感觉一样。我不明白你如何回到那样的小镇，回到所有的损失中，并生活在那里。你回来做什么？你甚至怎么开始克服它？
Watching the Tigers win, 21-19, completely outmatched, everyone together, cheering them on, I knew the answer.
看着老虎队以21比19获胜，完全处于劣势，大家在一起欢呼，我知道了答案。
Lisa Pollak.
丽莎·波拉克。
Our program is produced today by Jane Feltes and myself with with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Sarah Koenig, Amy O'Leary, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Chris Ladd.
我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）和我制作，与亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、黛安·库克（Diane Cook）、莎拉·柯尼格、艾米·奥利里（Amy O'Leary）和丽莎·波拉克合作。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）负责我们的网站。制作帮助来自托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）和克里斯·拉德（Chris Ladd）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
You know, you can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的档案中下载今天的节目。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our show by Mr. Torey Malatia, who's lobbying for this be our new national motto, printed right on the money.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督来自托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生，他正游说将其作为我们新的国家格言，印在钱上。
I'm proud to be American, but, I don't have time for horse [BLEEP].
我为身为美国人感到骄傲，但我没时间听这些狗屎话。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。